[موسيقى]
واذا استقبلته من جانبه الغربي رايته
منتصبا سامقا تلوح صفحاته البيضاء ورعانه
الشم وشماريخه الفارعه كما قال الشاعر
شاعر المعلق عمرو بن كلثوم فاعرضت اليمامه
وشمخرت
كاسياف بايدي
مسلطين قال تعالى
وعرضنا جهنم عرضنا جهنم يومئذ للكافرين
عرضه ثم ياخذ في الانحدار التدريجي مشرقا
حتى يلامس السهوله الشرقيه عند الدهناء
وبه فجاج متباعده طبيعيه ما بين كل فج
واخر مسافات متقاربه في القدر جعلها الله
سبلا للماره
ومنافذ للسيول
[موسيقى]
وجبل العارض هو اشهر جبال الجزيره العربيه
بعد سلسله جبال السنوات
واطولها امتدادا واكثرها سكانا واخصبها
واغناها واشهرها تاريخيا وابعدها ذكرى
امتد على سهل يقع شرق الدهناء وغرب عاليه
نجد او ما يسمى بالدرع العربي
وجنوبا بين الربع الخالي ونجران
وشمالا ينتهي بالزلفي في نفوذ الثويرات
فامتداده من الجنوب الى الشمال
حوالي 800 كيلو متر ومن الغرب الى الشرق
يتراوح ما بين 100 كيلو الى خمسين كيلو
متر واعلى قمه فيه تبلغ حوالي 1500 متر
فوق سطح البحر طبعا
[موسيقى]